[Music]
the thing that stopped the trade
conversation with odell beckham jr is
because the team that was most
aggressive in pursuing him
was the new england patriots the new
england patriots were trying to get
odell beckham jr all last off-season
that's chris sims yesterday stirring
things up and
sparking some reaction among patriots
fans among giants fans and
pretty much everyone with the idea that
when the patriots swooped in and showed
real interest in otto beckham jr trading
for otto beckham jr the giants
eventually realized um
maybe if the patriot and think about i
was i wrote something about this
yesterday chris
that they remember when they traded for
randy moss nobody thought randy moss had
anything left and he has one of the best
seasons of any receiver in nfl history
they traded for wes welker they traded
for uh chris hogan they traded for
brandon cooks and yeah they flipped him
after a year but still they trade i mean
they're trying to break free
i mean
guys they trade for tend to work out
more often than not better than the guys
they sign in free agency frankly when
they're willing to give up draft pick
compensation for somebody that means
they see something with that guy and
they saw something with beckham and and
uh as you said yesterday it caused the
giants to keep him and and i want to
spin this forward yeah um
because i still think and and that's how
this all came up in the first place last
week jay glazer made a bold direction
that he thinks beckham's going to be
traded i think there's a good chance
he's traded the 49ers are still
interested in this guy i don't know that
the patriots could pull it off now and i
don't know they want to pull it off
they've kind of made that shift toward
power running to set up the pass i don't
know that beckham is a guy that they
would want now the way that they may
have wanted him a year ago but the 49ers
are still in this and all it takes is
one team to be interested other teams
may get interested and i think this is
something that's going to heat up yeah i
i mean i agree i you know this is uh
again this is something i kind of knew
all throughout the season i had heard
this and then as the season went on i
talked to people and you know i know
people all around the league and it came
up a few times in conversation i think
this was known you know as far as an
under the radar fact in league circles
and of course that's why it did come out
you know jay glazier talked about it
last week you talked about he picked the
question to then answer it to say this
is the bombshell i think that will
happen you know this off season so he
knew that's why he kind of let it out
that way and i just figured hey
why not talk about that and kind of let
it out to what i know about the subject
in general it would have been
fascinating to see odell beckham jr up
there with the new england patriots i'm
amazed at the anger the patriot fans
showed at the fact that this could
happen i don't know
did they not want to go 16-0 or do they
not want to go 19-0 i don't under even
understand that but either way yes i
don't think all this trade talk with
odell beckham jr is done yet i don't and
i think there would be of course a
number of teams that would want to
pursue him not only because his talents
but like you've said before his contract
is quite favorable as well
kb on twitter says chris sims is an
idiot he talks and all i hear is charlie
brown's teacher that's good
that's good
but here's the baby eat it buddy you
don't know crap i know more than you
go ahead patriots
he's very humble and subtle there subtle
patriots fans are are always going to be
upset about anything that would go
against the status quo because they're
going to rally the the the troops around
the status quo that's just what they do
and look at it this way they won the
super bowl right so you know if you
change one of the factors in last year's
equation if you add otto beckham to the
mix what's that the best case scenario
is you're going to do what you did
anyway so i can understand why they'd be
a little hesitant the question is going
forward do you think it's something the
patriots would want to try to pull off
and would the giants even want the
30-second pick in the draft for odell
beckham jr plus whatever else the
patriots would throw on yeah they would
probably have to throw a lot of
sweetener in there to to begin with but
no i i would think that this would be a
year they can't pull that off you know
last year they had two first-round picks
right you know i think they've kind of
shaped their team to where they're going
in the future they're obviously going to
look for a quarterback at some point
probably another receiver they
definitely need to add that to their
roster but uh as far as odell beckham jr
do i think he would have worked in new
england i do because new england is the
most humble experience there is and he
loves playing football i know that but i
don't think this conversation's dead yet
mike
uh yeah i just don't i remember what
happened with chad johnson in new
england and you have to completely give
up who you are i don't know that that
would have worked
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports